♪
LEVEL OF CONFIDENCE THEY
HAVE HAD SINCE THEY STARTED
DOING IT MANY YEARS AGO.
AND BUSINESS HAS THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF CONFIDENCE.
>> Martha: THAT WAS
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN THE
CABINET ROOM EARLIER TODAY.
HE ALSO POINTED OUT WHICH HE
LIKES TO DO BUT IT'S A FACT.
LOOK AT THE CHART.
DOW IS UP MORE THAN 5,000
POINTS IN ONE YEAR.
IT'S NEVER DONE THAT BEFORE.
70 NEW HIGHS FOR THE DOW
JONES INDUSTRIALS.
REMEMBER WHEN EVERYONE SAID
THE MARKET WAS GOING TO TANK
THE DAY AFTER THE ELECTION
AND FALL THROUGH THE FLOOR?
IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
HISTORIC FAX TAX REFORM.
4% IN THE THIRD QUARTER.
WE WILL SEE IF THAT HAPPENS.
DOES HE KNOW EXACTLY WHEN
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
NEWLY PASSED BILL.
>> SO, MARTHA, LOOK, THE
HOUSE AND SENATE STILL HAVE
TO COME BACK AND FUND THE
GOVERNMENT AND THEY WILL DO
THAT PROBABLY OVER THE NEXT
WHEN WE SIGN THE TAX
LEGISLATION.
IF THEY GET THE CONTINUING
OF SOME OF THE LOOSE ENDS,
WE WILL HOPEFULLY TRY TO
SIGN THE TAX LEGISLATION ON
FRIDAY.
IF NOT MOST LIKELY WHY WILL
SIGN IT THE FIRST WEEK OF
QUESTION OF THE PAY GO.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Martha: IF IT'S SIGNED IN
THIS YEAR IT COULD MEAN 25
BILLION-DOLLAR CUT TO
YOU MIGHT WANT TO PUSH IT
INTO THE NEXT CALENDAR YEAR?
>> EXACTLY, MARTHA.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO DO THAT.
NEXT YEAR.
WE WOULD NEVER PUT A CUT IN
TO MEDICAID.
>> Martha: DOES THAT MEAN
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
SIGN IT AT MAR-A-LAGO AND
>> IF WE SIGN IT NEXT YEAR
WE WILL SIGN IT PROBABLY
AFTER JANUARY 1st WHEN THE
PRESIDENT IS BACK AND
PROBABLY SIGN IT SOMEWHERE
IN THE BEGINNING OF NEXT
THAT THE BILL GETS SUCH A
BAD WRAP, I GUESS.
WE HAVE SEEN IN THE PAST
THIS KIND OF LEGISLATION HAS
BEEN SUPPORTED BY DEMOCRATS
IN THE PAST THIS TIME AROUND
THEY ARE RAILING AGAINST IT
CHUCK SCHUMER IS.
IN GENERAL, DO YOU THINK?
>> YOU KNOW, MARTHA I THINK
>> YOU KNOW, MARTHA I PHINK
>> YOU KNOW, MARTHA I PEONK
MIND QUICKLY ON THIS BILL.
BY FEBRUARY 1stS THE IRS
PEOPLE WILL SEE A DIFFERENCE
IN THEIR PAYCHECK.
THEY WILL SEE MORE TAKE HOME
PAY ON FEBRUARY 1st.
RIGHT NOW FOR SOME REASON,
PEOPLE DON'T THINK THEY'RE
GETTING A TAX CUT.
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY ARE ACTUALLY GETTING A
TAX CUT.
WHEN PEOPLE ACTUALLY SEE
MORE TAKE HOME PAY IN THEIR
PAYCHECK, I THINK THEIR
PUBLIC OPINION IS GOING TO
CHANGE PRETTY QUICKLY.
TAX PAY CUT.
>> Martha: THEY WILL FEEL IT
OR THEY WON'T AND THEY WILL
BE ABLE TO DECIDE WHAT THEY
ULTIMATELY THINK ABOUT THE
BILL WHEN THEY SEE THAT.
IN TERMS OF THE CARRIED
GIVES HEDGE FUND PEOPLE WHO
RUN HEDGE FUNDS THE ABILITY
TO PAY FAR LOWER TAX RATE
THAN YOUR AVERAGE JOE.
THAT WAS SOMETHING THE
PRESIDENT SAID HE WOULD GET
FRIENDS HAPPY IN NEW YORK.
>> THE PRESIDENT TRIED TO
GET RID OF CARRIED INTEREST.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT THE
PRESIDENT ACTUALLY DID HERE.
THE PRESIDENT DELIVERED ON
HIS FOUR KEY INITIATIVES.
WHEN WE LAID OUT WHAT WE
WERE GOING TO DO IN TAXES,
WE TALKED ABOUT MIDDLE CLASS
TAX RELIEF.
WE TALKED ABOUT LOWERING
BUSINESS TAXES.
WE TALKED ABOUT
SIMPLIFICATION AND WE TALKED
ABOUT REPATRIATION.
THOSE WERE THE PRESIDENT'S
HIS KEY PRINCIPLES.
YES WE TALKED ABOUT GETTING
IF YOU LOOKED AT WHAT WE
ACHIEVED WE DID ACHIEVE
GETTING RID OF MANY, MANY
LOOPHOLES.
WE DIDN'T GET RID OF THEM
ALL BUT WE ARE PRETTY
EXCITED WHAT WE DID GET RID
QUESTION OF WAYNE LANIER.
THERE WAS HINT YOU MIGHT
WANT TO.
IF YOU DECIDED YOU WANTED TO
LEAVE THE WHITE HOUSE AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR AT ANY
POINT.
WHAT HAS CHANGED YOUR MIND
WORKING ON PRESIDENT TRUMP,
ECONOMIC AGENDA.
WE ARE ACHIEVING MANY GREAT
THINGS.
WE HAVE OTHER THINGS TO WORK
ON.
WE ARE STARTING TO WORK ON
THESE ARE ALL GREAT
THE AMERICAN ECONOMY AND THE
AMERICAN WORKER AND WHAT'S
GOING ON HERE AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT IT'S A ONCE
IN A LIFETIME OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK ON.
>> Martha: YOU WANT TO STICK
AROUND TO SEE THOSE THINGS
THROUGH.
HOW WOULD YOU SAY THE WORK
EARN ENVIRONMENT.
WE HAVE SEEN PEOPLE LEFT AND
>> I THINK THE MOOD OF THE
WHITE HOUSE TODAY IS EXCITED
WITH OUR ACCOMPLISH.
S.
BUT EVERYONE IS VERY
REALISTIC THAT WE STILL HAVE
A LOT OF WORK IN FRONT OF US
AND WE CAN DO SO MUCH MORE.
>> Martha: GARY COHN, THANK